We Begin this hour with our exclusive
interview with martial artist Tiffany
Chen who was also Robert De Niro's
partner back in April the couple
welcomed their first child together her
name is Gia Virginia Chen De Niro soon
afterward Tiffany chin lost all movement
in her face now an MRI revealed that she
has Bell's Palsy that's a neurological
disorder that causes severe muscle
weakness or facial paralysis only on CBS
mornings Tiffany Chen told us what it's
been like to lose her smile while under
very intense public scrutiny
before Tiffany Chen and Robert De Niro
started dating Chen a world champion
martial artist played as Tai Chi
instructor in De Niro's 2015 movie The
Intern how did he do
I've had better students but he was okay
he had a lot of other stuff to do in the
movie
I've had better students but he was okay
so how do you guys how do you go from
I'm the Tai Chi instructor teaching you
on the movie too now we're a couple it
just that's how it evolved when we were
working it was just work and then a
couple years later we got back in touch
and I said oh I guess we get along
and I guess we really get along on April
6th the couple welcomed their first
child together a girl named Gia Virginia
chin De Niro what was your pregnancy
like it was really easy really really
easy I mean I would joke around like
during the pregnancy you just keep
getting bigger bigger and bigger but I
was very active no so you're you're an
athlete so you're in very good shape and
I was just very in touch with my body
until I had this crazy new experience
where I didn't know what was going on
but I knew something
was wrong she describes the first sign
right after delivering
I noticed I was getting a sharp pain
behind my left ear like I was in the
room just after having my c-section what
did the doctors tell you it was when you
said the pain in your behind your ear
they kind of just looked at me blank
they just kept saying it's probably
because of the fluid buildup after
giving birth and then when I finally
could shower I remember looking at
myself in the mirror and saying
something definitely is looking
otter but it was all in the eyes and I
said well maybe I'm just off because I'm
I have so many meds pumped into me
when I got home it was like everything
was starting to just fall down on itself
like my face was melting on itself wow
and then a week after giving birth
that was when it all hit chin called her
doctor and was re-admitted immediately I
lost
all facial function the minute I got
into the hospital and the one thing that
threw everybody off was that it was
perfectly symmetrical how everything had
fallen and how everything just wasn't
working one of the doctors a couple
times I heard the doctor say do you
think it could be bells and they said no
Bells is only on one side she's
perfectly symmetrical yeah so you were
drooping on both sides yeah everything
fell and the craziest thing is you have
no idea how much your face does
without doing anything I got to the
point where my lower lip would fall and
even if I relax my face now my lip can't
fall that way I got to a point where it
was just hanging and I'd have to hold it
up and to talk I'd have to hold my chin
and I'd have to manipulate my lower lip
to make certain sounds I couldn't say
Bob so it was like having to speak to my
dad and say his name no I couldn't well
what was he saying to you during this
time about what was happening because
this was not his first baby so he has
seen pregnancy and yeah what was he
saying that what was happening he was
very sweet he tried to say that he
didn't see any difference he didn't see
any change he was like no he's like he's
like you look fine he's like maybe you
look a little Stern and I'm like really
my whole face is melted on itself but he
was
very strong very supportive treatment
for Bell's Palsy often include steroids
and antiviral medicine chin says she
tried steroids but is mostly relied on
acupuncture are you self-conscious about
your face the only I'm it's you know I
am and then I'm not I've never really
cared too much about what I look like
but what bothered me is that I couldn't
smile at the baby at the beginning and I
couldn't I couldn't give her kisses
that's what made me self-conscious and
then
we decided yeah we're going to live our
life and be social but you know how this
goes uh Bob De Niro one of the most you
know talented actors of Our Generation
has a baby at 79 that's news
and so the first time people see you out
in public that generates a lot of
conversation how did you take that what
was your reaction to the headlines
some of the things they said it takes a
lot of a pretty thick skin so I was kind
of I would see a lot of oh they're so
tired or they're this or they're that or
they look somber or they're not happy
and I mean they said those things it was
a little frustrating to see sometimes
and then everyone criticized you too
tired to smile like you said that you
don't look happy it just says you don't
know what's going on in people's lives
is my point yeah I'm like mind your own
business a bit and if you want to say
something don't always attach what you
think in your mind is the story you
don't know us you don't know what
happened in somebody's life why did you
want to sit and tell your story with us
today because I think that this is
something that
is private to us all in a certain way
especially if you've experienced it but
it shouldn't be kept so private that
people lock themselves in their homes
and women should not feel hurt by it
ashamed by it
or discard by it the thing I did worry
about was
what if it didn't get better
was my kid going to get made fun of for
having the weird looking mom
that's the only time like vanity comes
into play it's how it affects the child
I mean people were saying all sorts of
nasty things about you know my
appearance and
me being angry and I'm just kind of like
this is like the happiest time of my
life yeah but how did you handle the
nastiness you said it didn't bother you
I'm surprised yeah I was just sort of
like well you just see how many nasty
people are out there yeah and then when
you see how nasty people are you just
look at that and you're like well how
could I be better what could I do
to be better to educate people more and
to also help people who would normally
be scarred by these comments not be
scarred how can I be an ally to the
people who need the Ally and how is Geo
changed your lives
she's made it more fun it's okay
look at her hair Tiffany yeah she has a
son
[Music]
oh my God
my god look look over there you're
making your TB debut on CBS mornings yay
is she looking right at you
here's mommy over here
she is
here she is
that was hot gas that was a smile it was
legit yes Gia what's your favorite
Robert De Niro movie
which one do you like the one in the
delivery room the one in the delivery
room we're on the star yes you're the
star that's right okay this is my last
question you're the only one in the room
who can answer this at this particular
moment the best thing about Bob De Niro
is
how much he loves his family
that's nice that might make me a little
teary-eyed oh that's nice
foreign Tiffany says that Bob De Niro's
been very supportive of her during this
time and she's also been supporting him
after the death of his grandson earlier
this month at De Niro family certainly
been going through it he was at the
interview to cheer her on off camera and
of course he was invited to take part in
the interview but he made it clear I
took a picture of him looking down at us
he made it clear that this was her story
to tell he wanted to be there to support
her but he didn't want to take anything
away from what she had to say and I have
to say Bravo to Tiffany Chen because you
know she is not a mouse Burger girl
who's like oh what was me people were
talking about me this hurts my feelings
she said I really want to help other
women just to not be ashamed that this
that you have no control over this and
that you have to go on and live your
life despite how nasty people have been
to her and I was very touched by that
she's wearing sunglasses by the way not
because she's vain because she said you
know I came deliberately with no makeup
but because of this condition it hurts
her eyes the lights hurt her eyes so she
wears these she wears this on glass us
but I think it's a listen I never knew
that Bell's Palsy had a connection to
pregnancy no me neither I did not know
that yeah and she said a lot of women do
but a lot of women don't know and I you
know I'm very appreciative that she
decided to sit down with us Bravo to her
but also Bravo to you and the CBS team
that was a little bit of an emotional
roller coaster you're talking about this
disorder so right out the gate you grab
our attention and then you go from
Marriage to their relationship and of
course you pull out a baby yeah I mean
you're really pulling out of
heartstrings there but um Bravo that was
well done great oh and she's a martial
arts champion and she's won many medals
gold medals you know she's not very
accomplished she's not so funny it is
hilarious how was Bob as a student she's
got my best but he did okay I think
that's funny he's really terrific